médecine et médecins par le docteur
jacques sarano ce livre a été publié aux
éditions du seuil dans la collection
esprit autant dire que c'est un livre de
réflexion c'est le résultat même deux
c'est une réflexion sur vous même qui
était à l'origine de ces pas voulu
écrire un livre d'actualité je n'ai fait
que la rencontre et sur mes pas mais au
bout de quelques années
le design est exactement l'exercice de
la médecine j'ai voulu me reprendre
réfléchir un petit peu à ce que je fais
et à travers moi ce que nous faisons
tous les jours au sens de notre travail
au sens de nos luttes aussi et
poursuivant ce travail si vous voulez de
prise de conscience enfin de 2,2 vérité
j'ai voulu essayer de comprendre
moi-même et à travers moi de faire
comprendre à tout le monde de faire
comprendre non pas à mes collègues mais
surtout à ceux qui sont malades et à
ceux mêmes qui ne le sont pas exactement
le sens de notre travail nous a d'abord
intéressée de ce d'éclaircir ce qui
était pour vous les rapports entre les
malades et les médecins par exemple
oui et aussi autre chose j'ai voulu un
petit peu faire le tri faire le point et
surtout faire le tri entre ce qui est
tout de même essentiel est valable dans
notre travail de tous les jours
et ceux qui ne méritent pas de rester ce
que nous pourrions sacrifier assez
facilement tout en sauvant l'essentiel
est dans ce travail de tri j'étais amené
en occupant deux choses quotidiennes de
choses simples et assez directement
j'étais amené à rechercher les grandes
constantes de la médecine autant sur le
plan intellectuel que sur le plan
pratique que sur le plan social et que
sur le plan surtout humains nous voyons
d'abord ce qui mérite d'être sauvé avant
de voir ce qu'ils méritent
si vous voulez mon année eh bien je
crois que ce qu'ils méritent d'être
sauvées si on peut le donner en deux
parties est donc ça n'en fait qu'une
seule vraie c'est à la fois la rigueur
technique puis que l'objectivité la
vérité de notre travail qui nous lie un
petit peu les mains quand à des
thérapeutiques un petit peu
9 mais qui nous donne une certaine
solidité que nous donne notre éducation
la faculté c'est l'objectivité la vérité
la rigueur intellectuelle de notre
travail
il faut avant tout sauvegarder c'est le
côté si vous voulez techniques dont le
travail actuel qui est resté sur le mode
artisanal nous donne insuffisamment
l'occasion de nous avons ne vont pas
donner nous ont pas donné notre mesure
sur ce point du fait même du mode
artisanal de notes l'exercice de la
médecine actuelle augouard exercice de
la médecine était absolument artisanale
et bien il est artisanale pour nous pour
la plupart des médecins en ce sens que
nous restons individualiste la médecine
est resté une médecine de cabinet
qu'elle soit avec ses avantages et ses
inconvénients ses grandeurs et
petitesses mais du point de vue
technique il y a mieux à faire dans une
coordination meilleure soit des diverses
spécialités entraîne diverses techniques
d'entre elles soit des médecins
clientèle avec l'hôpital en particulier
ceux qui n'existent que dans les grands
centres et encore d'une manière qui
laisse un peu le médecin praticien un
peu à l'étranger à l'hôpital les
liaisons malgré les rapports ils sont
très bons laisse à désirer sur le plan
de l'organisation pu ou approché aussi à
la médecine d'être concurrentiels et ça
ça va être obligé d'avoir une clientèle
oui je crois que là encore est un autre
obstacle à la réalisation du double puis
dont je vous parlais qui est à la fois
technique objectifs et humain les deux
buts étant à séparables je crois que le
fait que la médecine et concurrentiel
aggrave son individualisme et ainsi
faisant du malade non pas seulement le
sujet et non l'objet de notre
sollicitude et de notre attention risque
de faire du malade il faut bien le dire
une tentation permanente de profits
puisque nous en vivons et je crois que
cette ce mode concurrentiel
individualiste et artisanale de la
médecine est ce qu'il faudrait arriver à
réformer par le groupage des médecins
entre eux et par une réforme du mode de
rémunération des médecins mais ceci est
un peu aller trop loin dans le sens des
réformes pratique je ne voulais pas
faire quelque chose de d'immédiatement
de réformistes simulés mais simplement
réfléchir au constant et à ce qu'elle
exige et comme premier pas de cette
exigence il avait des obstacles
il fallait bien
j'ai ouï mais je crois je reviens à ma
question je vous ai posé tout à l'heure
les rapports entre les malades et les
médecins l'ont été pour voix sujet de
réflexion si oui un sujet de trouble le
trouble oui le beau est peut-être un
petit peu fort j'ai hésité à le
conserver
le trouble c'est si vous voulez cette
sorte de traces psychologiques un pur de
quelque chose qui derrière est beaucoup
plus essentiel et qui est le rapport de
marne
le rapport de vie et de mort si vous
voulez entre deux êtres qui y sont
étrangers l'un à l'autre et qui ils sont
pourtant d'une intimité unique qui est
celle de l'avenir de quelqu'un et
combien de fois nous sommes séparés par
des barrières qui sont des barrières
soient techniques soient simplement de
des barrières commerciales si vous
voulez et ses barrières là nous empêche
de réaliser sainement ce quelque chose
de sous jacents qui que à travers quoi à
travers le que nous découvrons à travers
le trouble dans certaines situations
privilégiées
que faudrait-il faire pour que ces
relations soient idéales pour que ses
ratios relation cet idéal il faudrait
faire beaucoup et dans laquelle ne le
seront jamais mais je crois que
l'amélioration de l'organisation
l'organisation relations meilleures de
la médecine d'une part et une technique
même psychologiques améliorée dans la
formation du médecin en même temps
qu'une réflexion des médecins sur leur
rôle humain et qui commencent d'ailleurs
à se faire de plus en plus une
collaboration avec la malade plus grande
non seulement sur le plan individuel du
cabinet mais à une échelle beaucoup plus
importante et une chaîne de groupe amené
à collaborer avec les malades soit par
des revues soit par des réunions amener
des collaborations aussi avec les
administrations les collaborations enfin
avec l'école les assistantes sociales
les infirmières devraient amener au sein
même de la technique une médecine plus
humaine s'agit presque d'apprendre aux
gens à être malade finalement il s'agit
d'apprendre aux gens à être malade aux
médecins aussi à être malade de temps en
temps et au malade peut-être leur
apprendre qui peut ce qu'elle médecin
alors à prendre un petit peu à être
médecin c'est un peu difficile pour qui
avec vous écrit ce livre pour les
maquillages les écrits donc pour tous je
les écris un peu pour les médecins mais
ils n'ont pas grand chose à apprendre de
moi je les écris pour tous j'ai écrit
pour les malades
je les écris pour qu'ils ne nous
comprennent pour qu'ils comprennent un
petit peu le sens de notre travail qui
ne donne pas le médecin soit pour un
technocrate soit bourg comme on l'a dit
un petit industriel pressé mais un homme
comme eux qui risque d'être malade comme
eux et d'être sur la sellette comme oeuf
et pour les malades et aussi pour tous
ceux qui réfléchissent à la médecine et
qui aime faire lui qui voudrait faire le
point merci
[Musique]